大家好,继上集讲解到的成交量和量价关系,今天我要跟你们讲解他们的兄弟,能量潮指标,On Balance Volume,也被市场普遍上称为OBV。
这个技术指标极少人知道,但是它本身却是成交量方面相当重要的分析指标。
OBV指标主要是用于发现任何股票
分析股价趋势的一种技术指标
OBV现反应成交量的变化是特别明显的
这点可以帮助身为散户的我们
捕捉专家进场和出场的细节
所以只要学好这个指标
我们就可以跟着主力一起吃肉
顺带一提
多米星目前专注制作的影片是关于投资方面的
并打算制作一个技术投资的系列
例如支撑阻力,MAEMA,MACD,RSI等等不同的技术指标
让你能够学到种种不同的指标
从而建立属于自己的一套投资系统翻案
这其中也会穿插这座关于基本面的影片
因为多米君选股会以基本面作为基础
再以技术面去观察趋势,决定进场和离场的时机
除非只是想炒超短线的股
有信息学习的你可以订阅我的频道
并打开小铃铛
那么你就可以第一时间收到我的更新通知了
那么这个OBV线背后的公司是怎样来的呢
举个例子
今天是2021年1月2号
昨天是2021年1月1号
从X股票上市至2021年1月1号的OBV为1000万
1月2号的成交量为100万
而且当天股价上涨
那么1月2号的OBV为1000万加100万等于1100万
假如1月3号的成交量为200万
而且当天股价下跌
那么1月3号的OB率为1100万
减200万等于900万
假如当天的股价是上涨的
那么我们就要加成交量
相反的
假如当天的股价是下跌的
那么我们就要减成交量
在讲解实例前
我将讲解OB率线的一些基本形态和其背后的逻辑
当股价上涨而OB率线下降时
我们要稍微注意了
因为这代表买方无力
股价可能会即将开始下跌
掌握好这点
我们就可以抓住逃生了
赚一波就跑
相反的
当股价下跌而OBV线上升时
这代表买方有力
股价可能即将开始止跌回升
掌握好这点可以在低位加仓
多米君这招的胜率其实还蛮高的
所以看到这种情况
我会以清仓进场
等过后股价再升到了一些其他的技术指标时再加仓但是假如看错了股价下跌也必须要果断离场所以千万要在进场前就是好值存贵接下来我将讲解上升趋势中
OBV线的三种变化形态
第一种
OBV线慢慢上升
股价也几乎同时慢慢上升
量价关系配合得非常好
虽然过程中有些小回调
但是整体上还算的上市上升趋势
那么通常你可以用哪一种方法确定买点呢?
第一,当OBV线突破前期高点
或者第二,当OBV EMA线和OBV线交叉
OBV EMA线的天数建议设定少一些
OBV EMA5或者OBV EMA10都可以
因为OBV线在短期交易中才能发挥出最大的功效和威力
有些情况适合用第一种方法,但是不适合用第二种方法
有些则适合用第二种
而不适合用第一种
这个需要你自己下点功夫去研究你的股票
到底更适合用哪一种方法
第二种方法会有点像我在之前MA EMA那个视频里
讲解到的死亡交叉和黄金交叉
那时候我说到死亡交叉和黄金交叉都是有延迟性的
因为他们使用的是MA50和MA200
但是在这里
OBV EMA和OBV线交叉,几乎可以说是没有延迟性的
因为这里使用的是EMA线而不是MA线
而且使用的EMA天数更是短期的
所以你不用担心延迟性这个问题
多米君都是使用TradingView来看图的
由于TradingView本身是没有内建OBV加EMA这个指标的
所以我用的都是由其他用户自己编码的
在这里教你怎样去找这个指标
首先,打开Indicator
然后在search bar这里找OBV加EMA
我现在用着的就是这个
你可以自行选择你的EMA天数
记得最好是短期哦
第二种形态
OBV线急速上升
股价同时也在急短的时间内飞速上升
量价关系也是配合的非常好
这时候你应该开始小心了
当股价来到这个点时
OBV线开始快速缩减
这说明了买方力度开始变落
交易者应该及时离场
这样你就可以避开接下来大约8%的贴符
第三种
OBB线已经见顶并明显下跌
但是股价仍在弱势上涨
量价出现背离
量价背离其实就是股价和成交量往不同的方向走
还记得我在上一集有提到
成交量的变化是股价变化的前兆吗
这个案例就是很好的诠释
这种OBB线形态代表阻力已经开始彻底
加上在上升趋势顶部出现设计之星
交易者可以做好离场的准备了
讲完了上升趋势接下来我就来讲解股价下跌的OBV形态第一种OBV线以均匀的速度下跌股价也同步和OBV线均匀下跌
量价配合也是非常好
这背后的逻辑是买方的力量越来越弱
因此OBV线一直下跌
也很明显的可以看出股价处于下跌趋势
第二种,股价下跌
反观OBV线并没有明显的下跌
这背后的逻辑其实是庄家在洗盘
目的是要洗走持股不定的散户
为了庄家只是在洗盘而不是出货
所以这时候的买盘并不弱
这就能解释为什么OBV线并没有下跌
对这只股只有信心的交易者可以放心持股
前提是你要找到你持股的理由
不可以抱着赌博的心态来做出买卖的决定
一旦你持股的理由消失了就可以考虑离场
第三种
OBV线急速下跌
股价也在短时间内急速下跌
在这种下跌的情况中
你千万不能有捞底的念头
即使你是自身股票老鸟
你也很难在这种底部
捞到这种下跌趋势的股票
因为一底还有一底
你永远不知道这个跌势的底部会在哪里
正确的操作应该是等跌势停了
开始有基金在底部投入
OBV线也开始上升
你才进场
你可以选择在股价横摆趋势中
或者是确定突破了横摆趋势进入上升趋势才进场
各个的优势和越势
我必须要老实跟你说
你不能把欧益线单单这个指标
视为买入和卖入的指标
刚刚我给你看的一些实例
是按照原理和其背后的逻辑正确发展的结果
但是在限制市场中
也有不少不跟着这些原理和逻辑发展的结果
但是只要有正确的投资思维
不把股市当作股场
多用点时间研究基本面
再用技术指标去决定进场而离场的时机
你可以赚得不少
多比进可以说这个是我的自胜指标
OVVTR EMA13真的是太强大了
在我有用这个指标决定进场而离场的时候
我的胜利高达82%
平均整体盈利高达18%
接下来我来分享关于近期用这个指标的操作
第一支股市EFORS
这只股属于科技板块
主要做软件的
我在10月8号的0.5价位买入
原因是因为OBB和EMA线交叉
并有OBB向上
过后在11月5号大成了一波
这时候我在0.595这个价位
套递了60%的持股
一直到11月25号的0.63价位
卖出剩余的40%
因为OBB线和EMA线交叉
并有OBB向下
结上那时候大致开始负面
想着落袋为安为上侧
第二个我要分享的骨则是通关这只骨主要是做塑料包装的基本面还算不错我在8月20号的2.49价位买入原因也是因为OBB和EMA线交叉
并有OBB向上
还有另外一个原因就是季度业绩即将在8月26号恐怖
因为我相信它的业绩会不错
过后在9月13号时
我全数套利在2.89这个价位
因为OBB和EMA线交叉
并有OBV向下
加上这个价位即将逼近3.0的关键心理支撑阻力线
希望你能从我这两个实力中学到一些知识
假如你喜欢这种个股的分析
以及买入和卖出的理由
欢迎在下面的留言区让我知道
假如反响不错的话
接下来我也可能会出这样的一个系列
最后
让我来讲解OBV线这个指标的优点和缺点
和做一个小小的总结
让你自行判断OBV线这个指标
到底是否适合加进营投资系统吧
我就来先讲解它的优点
第一
OBV线能有效地判断市场短期波动
第二
OBV线能有效地帮助投资者确定
在股市突破盘局后的发展方向
第三
OBV的走势能有效地局部显示主要资金的移动方向
也就是庄家的动向
这可以显示那段时间不许长的成交量
是排位在低位还是高位
中而使你领先一步深入了解市场的内部原因
讲完了它的优势
接下来就来讲讲它的劣势
第一,适合用在短期是一把双刃剑
因为这限制了它在中长期的使用
所以多米琴只会在短刷的时候用这个指标
中长期的话对于这个指标就看看罢了
因为对我来说还有更适合我的指标
第二,OVP指标是由Joseph Graham有提出的
由于这是建立在像美国这种比较成熟的股票市场
所以用在马股上会有一点点影响
这是因为马股大多数个股庄家都控盘较重
导致股价在上涨过程中没有获利筹码兑现
股票会涨得很疯
但是成交量并没有明显增加
OPV就自然无法发挥本身的作用
第三,庄家同样是把双刃剑
OPV可以用来观察庄家的动向
也可以被庄家发出来的烟雾弹影响
要破解这种迷惑的操作
你可以使用选择比较短时间的OBV线
例如60分钟
30分钟
甚至是15分钟
来更仔细看清楚这几种装甲的动向
好了
那么今天我对OBV线的讲解就到这里了
希望今天你对技术投资的学问又更进一步
如果你觉得这个视频对你有帮助
欢迎在下面留言你的学习心得
点赞和订阅我的YouTube频道
我们下个影片见
最后我是多米追
一个喜欢讲故事的男人